he's made his first super bowl after
winning his first playoff games now
plural
back here on the rich eisen show how are
you andrew
what's going on rich appreciate you
having me on you bet thanks for calling
in uh
give voice to the ram sense of things
with everybody talking about how
uh the saints should be the ones going
to atlanta because of the blown call
andrew
uh you know what we just feel happy that
we you know went through that game the
adversity that we faced and uh found a
way to win it
and you know richard played 13 years
i've seen a ton of games i've had a ton
of calls that could have gone one way or
the other or should have or
whatever that have been claimed to be
missed uh you know what
but i also lost the playoff game to a
coach being on the field
getting a personal foul drawn from our
players and you know so i mean i've
experienced it man and i know it's tough
but the reality is football was played
after that snap
and uh you know what whatever team tries
to win the game from there and wins it
uh
you won the football game so what was
your perspective when you saw it did you
think it was a flag
andrew i mean where were you honestly i
was on the other end of the field
looking down from the angle so honestly
i couldn't really tell where the ball
went or whether it hit somebody or what
i just saw the contact
and had no idea at the time you heard
the fan reaction and all that
that kind of stuff so um obviously you
knew something they didn't agree with
but uh you know what plays happen man
and and reps make mistakes right you
know
just like we do and everyone else does
in their job
and uh you know what but the bottom line
is there was a lot of mistakes made in
the game i mean i think there's multiple
pictures across the league of
how many times the clock was on zero
when they snapped it and the different
face mask calls that were missed in the
game and
to me it's just it's hard to say that
the last foul is the foul you want to
argue about that's missed i mean if
you're going to argue about that one
then you have to go back and fix the
others and so you know what uh i just
think that's a tough argument just
because it's the last foul
and i said uh prior to you calling in
andrew
i i'm i'm wondering at what point will
the rams use this as a rallying cry
within the locker room the
the quintessential nobody believes in us
people don't think we deserve to be here
normally that's just uh something that's
drummed up
out of whole cloth to try and get a team
fired up for a big game except this time
there's a lot of people who don't think
you deserve to be there
andrew yeah you know and that's uh
everyone's entitled to their opinion but
like i said rich is you know you see the
arguments from some of the saints
players about
you know that the rule about the
commissioner starting the game over or
from that point or whatever
my argument to that would be rich is
then jared goff got a face mask on the
second down right before the possession
before that was not called that would be
first and goal with the one down three
points
if you look at our odds from the one
this season that's seven points
so they'd be down four and the field
goal wouldn't matter they've had scored
in that situation either way
so been out since the playoffs started
and since we lost two games in the month
of december
and uh you know what we've done nothing
but proved different than that since and
we don't plan on changing
andrew whitworth rams offensive tackle
four-time pro bowler here on the rich
eisen show were you
surprised when the word came in from the
the sideline after again that there was
no
uh face mask penalty and you had a
fourth and
inches essentially on the goal line were
you surprised that the call came in from
the sideline that you were going for a
field goal
andrew you know i think in the situation
you look at it
uh the three points really matter to
keep it a tie game and give it a
possession where we really felt like
head to head with him in the second half
uh we had really felt like we were go
out playing them
and had the opportunity to win that game
so to get the tie you know you see that
but knowing sean mcvay and being around
him as much as i have
i'd be lying if i didn't say my first
reaction is i can't believe we're
kicking it
uh you know i i was i was flo i was
shocked and i was like you know what
this is a really smart thing to do
but uh i'm shocked that my guy's doing
it
i've tweeted out it was like a a veteran
coffee drinker suddenly ordering decaf
you know yeah i i agree with you that's
uh you know what uh
he's wise beyond his ears sometimes and
that was one of those situations where i
think he fought the
uh the you know the immediate response
to go forward and said you know what
what's the best thing to do in this
situation of the game with the momentum
where it is and
and uh he went for the kick so uh you
are
from louisiana as we discussed when you
were here in studio last week you won
state championships there as a high
school player and i mean there meaning
the super dome
obviously your bcs championship without
lsu
uh in that spot was that the loudest
you've ever heard that building
andrew uh it's not it's not even close
that was an extremely loud arena and uh
man what a what a place i mean
you can't do nothing to give a ton of
credit to the fans in that city man
you know it's always been a special
place a place i think a lot of and
what a what a job they did to support
their team and how loud it was uh
that was that was unbelievable um you
know it just
you left there with a ton of respect for
the culture and the atmosphere of that
city and how much they believe in their
football team
yeah you know i've never seen and you
could tell me if this was a first for
you or if you were aware of it at the
time
and this is another uh a great call on
the spot by mcveigh
to call a timeout i've never seen a
quarterback go run out to the numbers
to get into the ear of a wide receiver
to try and relay
something that golf was doing at the
time i've never seen that before
andrew have you yeah yeah it was
unbelievable i mean honestly we
lost communication there and uh you know
you just we
we thought maybe that some verbal stuff
would be able to happen but it just
nothing at all and so
uh actually the the headset and jared's
helmet uh
you know crazily and shockingly all of a
sudden didn't work rich
and uh he actually had he actually had
to play uh play a series with the backup
quarterback's helmet on at one point
um you know it's it's uh like i said man
there's a lot of things that go into
these games
and uh you know what we're just happy we
got out there with a w
so uh noticed on your twitter account
which i follow a whitworth
77 you tweeted out 77s never looked so
beautiful or what
or i think is what you said and it's a
photograph of you looking at your
rams throwback jersey with the super
bowl 53 logo stitch
on the upper left shoulder with the c on
the upper right what did that mean to
you
to see that andrew uh you know it's
tremendous rich i was actually
i got in early yesterday morning i was
like the first guys in the building and
had the opportunity to kind of walk
through and just
you know talk to some of the people in
the building and that we hadn't seen
since the game was over and
i happened to be walking through the
equipment room and they were actually
literally patching my jersey at that
moment
and i just stopped get my phone out and
took a picture real quick
uh because it was just you know it was a
surreal thing to see
uh to have that opportunity i think uh
you know just can't be more proud of the
team and the effort of everyone
involved in that building and uh you
know proud to represent the football
team
so it's another prep week right is that
what you're calling it's not a buy it's
apparent that's right
you remember yeah you're a good study
man you remember this this is not about
a week
yeah i know this is a prep week man
we're preparing we're preparing this
week
okay and part of that uh no doubt is to
prepare
for everybody's posses to come what is
the whitworth posse look like right now
for super bowl 53
for you oh man just you know trying to
figure out how to work all the do not
disturb buttons on your uh
you know your apple products is the main
thing but uh
you know what uh you know it it you'll
be the kids and the in-laws and the
parents and
sisters and brothers and all that good
mess and you know the goal right now is
really to get that over with and figure
out
all of that you know in the next two
days and then from then on man it's it's
preparing to try and go win a
championship
yeah i know so what's the grand total do
you think of the whitworth posse the
number
what's it what do we got uh you know i'm
staying out of that rich that's not my
department
that's uh miss whitworth uh no i know at
work that's her
i'm gonna let her i'm gonna let her be
in charge of that i'm gonna stay out of
there so if we set the line at 25 are we
taking over or under on the number of
whitworth policy members
for the super bowl well i'll say this
the the ones that uh
i'll be coming on my dime will be under
25.
[Laughter]
uh andrew thanks for the call man i
really love our chats for you coming in
last week i i i'm gonna take credit i
will take credit i chose the rams to win
the super bowl before the season you
came in before your
visit to the superdome and you won uh so
uh i think i'm a factor i'm not gonna
lie and and i hope we chat during the
super bowl week too
hey man i'm i'm on your side brother i
appreciate it and uh you know what i'm
looking forward to your training
sessions coming up man
i uh you know what we're gonna get that
number down this year i can't wait to
see it will you help me
i'm in man we'll we'll work some get off
man well what is your what what
did you run at the combine uh it wasn't
very good but
uh you know what uh i was about i don't
know i probably weighed like 3 35 or so
and i want to say i ran maybe a 5 1
maybe somewhere in there what what was
the number brock when we have it
five one five oh my gosh three five one
see
there we go carrying it three thirty
three plus
bills of five one five that is
remarkable
okay you're in you're on my training
team you're in andrew
come here man well take care of your
business first then you can take care of
mine okay
there we go we'll put priorities in
order thanks again andrew congrats on
making the big game
yeah i appreciate it rich thank you
that's andrew whitworth of the los
angeles rams
the rich eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern
on audience